it appears you're out of options tell me
about the threat known as inferno
professor Langdon we need your help
three days ago a man killed himself we
think he was part of something much
bigger
there was a package in his pocket and
what was it it's Dante's Inferno not
they defined our modern conception of
Hell 700 years ago but these circles of
Hell have been rearranged
why don't they why this map of Hell
Dante Dante's death mask yes we've got
to get the Florence
I need access to Dante Massa that they
must is no longer here it was stolen
here's the security footage professor
that looks like you I have no memory of
taking that knife you did I just saw you
I want to know what I'm involved with
why was someone shooting at you
everything is out of focus professor you
are having visions aren't you the people
behind this will do anything to protect
the truth you have no idea what they are
capable of this is what I have been
seeing what look this is not in the
original painting here's another one
prophecy done things Inferno isn't
fiction it's a prophecy someone created
a plague our population is spiraling out
of control Inferno is the cure they're
gonna wipe out half the world's
population unless we find this virus
they left a trail you have to trust your
own thoughts for a while
human lives are at stake the plague
exists you know what governments for you
to get it
the professor has become a liability
let's get it
there's always a way out it's nice to
have you back professor Fitness plague
is real we only have 48 hours to stop an
extinction-level event I will do
everything I can to find it